はじめ）マリファナ？
はじめ）俺は大丈夫です
たなっち）サブですか？　はじめ）サブです
はじめ）作りますよ全然
やふへゐ先生）いやいやいや
はじめ）あ、全然
やふへゐ）いやいや、なになになに
はじめ）いや、いいですよ　大丈夫
やふへゐ）怖い怖い怖い　怖い
はじめ）大丈夫ほんとっす　座っててください　大丈夫っす
はじめ）大丈夫っすよ
やふへゐ）食べて良いんすよね？
はじめ）あ、全然大丈夫っす
やふへゐ）あーあの人って綺麗すぎて無理なんすよね
はじめ）確かにねぇ
やふへゐ）ちょっとだけ、たなっちちょっとだけ
やふへゐ）キツ
たなっち）ちょっとだけしか食べませんよ
やふへゐ）助かりました
やふへゐ）ちょっとだけ　悪いですね
はじめ）ちょっとだけっすよ
やふへゐ）そして4分を切ってしまいました
やふへゐ）あんまりカットもしないレベルですか？
はじめ）あんましなくても良いと思います
やふへゐ）あ、ああいうのがマジでうまいってなったらイケる
やふへゐ）これうまいけどｗ
だいち）ようへいくん　やふへゐ）はい
だいち）ちょっといいすか？
だいち）髭剃りの続きを
やふへゐ）ああ
だいち）してもらっても良いですか？
だいち）うまい棒僕もすごく…
やふへゐ）ああ
だいち）今日じゃなくても…
たなっち）ようへいくん
やふへゐ）はい
たなっち）ちょっといいすか？
やふへゐ）あ、さっきのやつっすか？
はじめ）ちょっとメイン撮ってこようかなぁ
たなっち）どこだっけなんか…
はじめ）無料ちょいら(?)ヒャッホー
やふへゐ）うわ、今日白Ｔ着てこんけりゃよかった
（ピンポーン）
はじめ）ん？　たなっち）ん？誰か来た
たなっち）すいませーん
やふへゐ）はい
やふへゐ）もしもし？
はじめ）すいません1回あのアレから見た方がいいかもしれません、穴とか
やふへゐ）たなっち
はじめ）たなっち行ってきてあげて　たなっち）はい
たなっち）やばい
たなっち）だいちくんのイタズラでした
はじめ）だいちくん？
たなっち）ツイッター用の動画らしいです
はじめ）なにやってんすか
やふへゐ）いった
やふへゐ）ふふｗｗこれｗえ？
やふへゐ）ちょっと待ってｗええ？ｗｗ
はじめ）そう見てます、サムネイルの研究
やふへゐ）絶対さこれｗねぇ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
はじめ）実は3回くらい増やしました
やふへゐ）嘘？
はじめ）ようへいくんありがとうございます
やふへゐ）いや嘘でしょう、食べんのこれ？